dos mensajes fundamentales el primero
salvarla golpeada economía británica y
el segundo unir al país en esta
situación tan compleja y además unir a
su partido sobre la prioridad aliviar
las familias en la crisis del costo de
vida ha dicho que para recuperar la
economía está listo para tomar las
decisiones difíciles que haya que tomar
y advirtió que se viene en tiempos
complejos para el Reino Unido dijo que
pondrá la estabilidad y la confianza
económica en el centro del gobierno
sobre la unidad nacional
Richi sunat ha dicho que está listo para
hacer el Primer Ministro de la unidad
que se necesita en este momento más allá
de las diferencias políticas y como lo
hemos escuchado de sus propias palabras
ha pedido el mandato de la gente un voto
de confianza para cumplir con estas
promesas ha dicho además que está listo
para enmendar los errores que cometió la
poder administrar listas y además en un
clarísimo mensaje a Boris Johnson que
seguramente lo hará pensar en su futuro
político es que aseguró que el mandato
ganado por los conservadores en las
elecciones generales de 2019 no es
propiedad de Boris Johnson sino del
partido y ahora de Richard
también hablemos de lo que sigue se
espera inicialmente no la presentación
de su gabinete
sí habrá que ver quién es de listras se
mantienen en el cargo y quienes salen se
da como un alta probabilidad que la
actual ministro de finanzas Jeremy Hunt
que fue designado por listas hace dos
semanas se mantenga para seguir dando
estabilidad a los mercados pero lo
cierto Es que en estos momentos están
haciendo esas negociaciones Qué tipo de
fragmentos Qué tipo de sectores del
partido van a ingresar al gabinete
porque Richie hizo una acá prometido la
estabilidad y la unión del partido
conservador Así que se espera que no
solamente nombre a quienes lo apoyaron
sino también a lealistas de Boris
Johnson por ejemplo de hecho hace
instantes renunció el ministro de
comercio Jacob Richmond que ha sido
desde hace muchos años un lealista Boris
Johnson y también lo fue de Liz tras
también hay expectativa por conocer
ocuparán los grandes cargos del estado
como secretario de exteriores ministro
del interior y también sirven wallas que
es el actual ministro de defensa Será
ratificado porque hace pocos días
anunció su apoyo público a Boris Johnson
si corría en esta elección para Primer
Ministro como lo mencionabas Richi es
una hace historia hoy porque se
convierte entonces en el primer premiere
británico de origen indio y el más joven
de la historia con apenas 42 años